hi my name is Lester Jew a graduate
student from University of
wisconsin-madison I'm at home base
called machine learning on and protest
diffusion clustering tree America
analysis in space-time metric space
Oh hi everyone my name is LAN century a
graduate student of the University of
wisconsin-madison
I'm so happy to present here a metal is
called machine learning on can protest
diffusion cluster three emergy analysis
in space-time metric space protons for
straighter can control have gained
momentum since done from top office in
2017 the mass shooting case in matrix
domain stockless high school in Fabri
2018 and the national walker said
another waves of control products across
the country this from our products have
led me to raise a question to have huge
social impact how have this can control
protests spread within the United States
the existing mathematical model for
diffusion and for social movements
mostly focuses on either time or space
dimension but they seldom combine the
two the time from mathematical model
focuses on time versus the lump of
participants it can be time serious or
differential equations of proof but the
geographical variation and limit and for
the special one it evaluates outbreaks
statistically and the analytical ability
for of the theories I also limited and
this project does just that I try to
combine this time and space dimension
and form a combined space-time metric
space before I move on
okay I slowed this one down before I
move on I would like to explain the main
object of this project so what is the
fit what is diffusion and why do we
concern about diffusion so so logically
speaking
diffusion refers to the spread of
something within a social system for the
K
of social products they're a nightmare
encourage many fads to the subsequent
effects so that means if you join a
protest or if your friend joined the
protest it's likely that we would want
to join too
and so that you work perfectly factor
plays a key role in the spread of the
movements for in just me my fusion in
2012 test web across the Middle East we
can see that the drug geographical
fetter
really matters so now it is the
visualization of the data there are more
than 2600 can related products from
March 2017 to 22,000 80 and this is the
time crystal that I've mentioned
combining the space and the time
dimension you can see the excesses the
space of spatial dimension that is the
longitude latitude and the CSS at the
time dimension you can see each top
represent one products offense and the
lump of protest just skyrocket since
spring 2018 Oh after the master decays
in parkland there are three big waves on
the community projects namely the
schoolgirl the match of our lives and
the Lighting's anniversary of the
Columbine High School massacre you can
see inside this time crystal there's a
vessel shape of United State and of this
transpose to a Unitas may a map of
United States just at the bottom and
there's a cloud of dust as the
constituent of time crystal and it looks
like a Coulomb map of astrophysics so
you
ask there lots of dust so which dust
will lead to which one and what the
relationship between the dust and how
they can be grouped into different
clusters to answer this question I will
apply a taluk comb cluster analysis
which is a machine and in Tallaght
especially in the unsupervised learning
and this talaq is mostly for the task of
grouping and here we are we have this 3d
plot you can see that the lapew llem map
the dust of chloral allow separate in
the light different clusters and right
using the comparative metric space of
space-time metric space we we can now
have a well-defined euclidean distance
so digital they have a distance between
and i can measure some of the tasks may
have a shorter distance between the tool
and some of them may have a longer
distance and this cluster analysis
technique would group the laboring test
into the same cluster still allowed we
have my cluster and before moving on i
would like to look at hella coupon that
is what is the ratio between time and
space that is how many days in time is
equivalent to how many how many
kilometers in space
in fact this ratio lead to make sense
sociologically so to speak and our
hypothesis is that when one protests
occur in one cavity some people may
encourage the friends or families or
congress to join a protest or start a
protest somewhere else so we will
measure the last Zoey distance of
travels
of people making necessary trip from one
County to another County inside the
country and the space-time ratio would
take consideration of this so you can
see we can also group the cluster in
absolute ellipse oh and also in the
convex hulls and now we may ask um what
do all this mean
what is the relationship between this
cluster to let's say the master decays
we want to see the relationship between
the two and we will mostly focus on the
Saffir master in cases there's a special
value theory in statistical modeling and
in Susilo sociology that is some
potential value is very important and
the system may have different behavior
before and after the Thresher value for
the case of the products or for the case
of the masculine case if they're more
than certain people being window cute
image disproportionately from more
attention from the public and for this
study special value that I said as five
or more people being killed and night or
more people being ruined you can see the
Westport and yellow spots represent the
Thresher value that I've mentioned and
the black spots is the cases death of
you both the conditions just one part
line case and you can see different
severe cases inside that I'm crystal so
now I can combine the clusters and the
master decays you can see there are
significant relationship between the two
the masculine case touch the bottom of
the
clusters it just like our disposal
supporting some floating Mecca stones
let's say notorious Harlan shooting case
touch the bottom of the clusters of the
three resistors goooo commercial for
life's clusters and for this big one
there are some wet sports and also okay
limbs and also some yellow and this one
yellow in westport touching the bottom
of the cluster so that means is some
kind of machine in case initiate the
cluster but there's also a question
inside each cluster how do one protest
lead to another tell us how to protest
diffuse and it has the chase of the
project I use a technique called
spanning tree which is an in graph
theory does a tree that include all the
vertices of the grass or of the graph
with minimum possible number of edges I
make the spanning tree for different
cluster so we have like lustre
we have Lanai trees and it has the
fourth tree and it has the fifth one and
it is typically because cluster inside
each cluster
I'm construct a spanning tree formed the
leveling of the protests that means the
edge of the tree means to jump between
the protests that is from one products
lead to another one so we now have the
tree and we want to know how to model
this job or model the edge of the
spanning tree statistically
so we would use italic in probability in
statistic come maximum likelihood
estimation Emily in short we can see
that the charm of the protests basically
follower exponential distribution the
left one is the probability plot
comparing to Alamo distribution and the
white one is the probability density
function of the drum
there's the PDF so you can see the curve
of the exponential distribution fit a
statistic quite well by using MLG we can
find out the parameters lambda of
exponential distribution model this one
I mostly use exponential dispersion and
I try to use another one but didn't
quite the PDF well so I didn't you you
can say qualitatively but but by Emily
mostly we choose the model first and
then we determine the parameters for
this one I think also makes sense to use
exponential distribution as clue in the
diffusion we assume that the
geographical data matter so that means
the laboring candy or the laboring
occasion is much more probable to to be
in fact by the laboring location so
that's why I picked exponential
distribution and it is why I chose this
one
so I yep
so for this one are mostly I want to
find a simple modeling form the jump
process so that we can have we can
further analyze all the jump by using
the model yeah so that's why I picked
this one in fact the previous study
didn't did didn't combine the space and
time are very frequently the most most
of the time they look at dumb process
separately so for this one I combined it
and I try to see how the term really
looks like yeah so I just pick something
that is reasonable and simple and
exponential distribution is the one that
I picked probably there may be some
other more complicated distribution that
fits this one fit test statistic more
but exponential distribution is a
reasonable choice
and then I want to show how the
diffusion really looks like on the
United States map it is one of the
cluster before the three big waves of
our products there's a that is a cluster
from October 2017 too much circuit
without any tea in the west coast of the
United States you can see that the
protest originated from softened
California and then spread out we can
surf that the laboring countries are
more likely to be inferred by the
counties they already have products and
then it takes some time to spread out
the products which is a different
pattern to the bursts that I'm now going
to explain this is another cluster which
is located inside the time of waste that
is the free back raises of protests from
a much third too much 31 2018 also in
western United States you can see their
purse of products at one moment just all
of the products explore and of them just
appear in in a single moment so you can
see that the geographical factors are
much less eloquent and of them just
happen in a very short timeframe that
means the previous month
the geographical diffusion adds on a
longer time frame and this one adds on
the relatively short a time free to sum
up there are two main drivers our in
diffusion namely the geographical
diffusion and the burst the spreading
pattern of them are different
the first one is more graphical and the
segments have less geographic open and
fenced order in the land we can expect
the pattern of the purse would happen
much more frequently than the past and
we can also use different kind of to to
analyze this two type of pattern for the
geographical diffusion we can use italic
of this project that is the cluster tree
ma Yi analysis for geographical
diffusion and for the first I will
suggest some more traditional italics a
time series for for the burst
it is also expect that the italic of our
cluster tree and ma yi analysis can be
applicable to other areas recovering in
fashion and other areas of diffusion may
say the contagious disease or others
social practices I would like to
summarize my presentation by using a
quotation from Albert Einstein who says
priming space other conditions in which
we left but most by which we think I
hope my presentation have provide some
level ways of data visualization and
data analysis for social problems and it
can make us to rethink time and space
sociologically and that's the end of my
presentation thank you and I'm happy to
take any questions